what's happening there reject nation craig and
john here today we are going to continue moon
night with episode five today after that insane
cliffhanger from last week and before you ask
nope sorry Coy Jandreau will not be with us
today you let him explain it i know there's
a really good reason he couldn't actually
be here today unfortunately but he will be
joining us for the finale you better be Coy
you're watching this without him being here
that means we'll have to step up our game today
be just a sharpness and be just as fast talking
to you guys if you can though leave a like that'd
be very much appreciated also subscribe and click
that notification bell get notified when our
reaction for the finale is up as always full
length watch alongside sync with the time code
for our super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page along with a bunch of other shows and i did
want to mention too that the real rejects podcast
is up what we've been doing currently is like for
the moon night for example we'll upload the review
portion of this video since those are usually like
10 to 30 minutes long yeah guys if you want like
just audio commentary version of us go check us
out over there anywhere where podcasts are found
guys let's get into this and also thank the damn
prepper boys thank you guys probably said this now
hey guys just wanted to say that if
you normally don't stick around for
the discussion part after the reaction i'm
actually really proud of the discussion that
we had of this particular episode afterwards
so i heavily encourage you to do so if you
normally don't that's all i wanted to say
enjoy the reaction this is all you're [ __ ]
calm down whoa yeah you told me that you
were in a place that was oddly reminiscent
of this office except that it was in egypt
right and that you were with a rhinoceros
you're right it was a hippopotamus
do you think that is sense or nonsense somewhere
in between you were talking to me about a boy
do you remember that boy you think you
could tell me about to have a little boy
looks like a film school light in the back
oh yeah i mean they always pay you a lot of
money in this place you're really good i'm
gonna set myself up thank you doctor oh boy
oh [ __ ] uh-huh okay here we go i
only see one of them in the mirror
you'd be surprised how many intersectional
planes of untethered consciousness exist
yeah ah like the ancestral plane oh the
ancestral plane they flat-out mentioned
it she been through wakanda right through
these doors for example we go through here
there's gonna be a bunch of patients and
there's crawley probably about to yell
well done well if your heart's balanced in life
then you will spend eternity in paradise the
field of reeds but uh before we get there
i've just got to do a quick little oh boy
she's weighing our hearts on the scales of justice
hmm oh nice what if they don't balance you get
thrown overboard the dead will drag you down into
the duet kill the hippo steal the vote there's
chaos in you yeah buddy why is it moving like
that i don't know i do not have a card for this
this boat contains all of her life's memories
but my advice get in there and show each other
the truth flashbacks and bring us jake lockley
yeah i don't know it's the street you know how
many streets have you walked down your
whole life there's a cab in the back
gotcha they're all yours what do you know
these people yeah i kept wishing i'd fail
and one of them would kill me instead the
healing ended up being a curse [ __
] you are not helping our afterlife
little mark what's your name oh hold on
there wait a moment wait wait a moment
this little mark running off
to his bat mitzvah mazel tove
we'll eat later boys you're gone too long
i got jj abrams to be in this show man yeah
great cameo latest gate is mom said
not to when it's raining that'll be
fine don't be a baby ain't nothing man
gonna happen today do we wrong kid dead
oh creepy
gotta face your traumas man this is all your
fault this is all your fault oh boy wendy please
we just about to blow out the candles now that's
harsh we'll do it just you and i this year
okay can't have a birthday
without your favorite cake
you were always jealous of him i should've
known you would do something like this
there's so many stairs in this
place i know it's bowser's staircase
origins turns out going awol in a fugue
state gets you discharged from the military
didn't have a ton of options after that so i
went work for hire for my old ceo bushman bushman
called for no witnesses and i couldn't live with
that is that gotcha hey that's that red scarf
oh he didn't make it explains why
that color has been showing up so much
ghost of specter past
ah this music cool this is so cool
what a waste
to be my final word against the evil doers
your mind i feel it fractured yes broken
most fascinating damn takes advantage of him in
exchange for your life do you swear to protect
the travelers of the night and bring my vengeance
to those who would do them harm sneaky old vulture
as my moonlight
the first time we called them my moon
night and this year i think so yeah
can you send word to layla please
help us free conscious please tell it
you have to help us what the heck
cyrus is not going to like this hey
all those people die it'll be all
your fault no no no no no you can't i
wow did you inject me with something he's found
a barrier here in his own mind here that's insane
do you think you created stephen to hide from all
the awful things you feel you've done in your life
or do you think stephen created mark to punish
the world for what your mother did to you
fascinating there can be no progress without
understanding can you open up to stephen
still needs a guide right now
open this door
oh boy bloody hell look at the scene of this
place but it's right out before months easy wow
just scales knocked to stephen grant action
figures off the table even girl has no fear
open the door right now
you're gonna learn
oh
no not meant to see that that's the whole point
of you oh wow well you want to remember the truth
that you had a mother that beat you
that made your life a living hell
you're lying just trying to upset
me but you've gotten to live
thinking that she loved you that she
was kind that she's still alive oh
god she's i speak to her every day what are you
talking about you're always leaving messages
no no no no no no no no no no thank you no
let me out let me out let me out let me out
stephen i'm your doctor you're a doctor
i'm here to help you dr harrow yeah is it
yeah look at that wow oh you've really
gone up in the world haven't you
a little haircut a little silly tash
there it's very ned flanders yeah
vocally dokly after your mother passed that's
not true oh i'm i'm so i must you say that
again my mother is alive you say that i
can i will freak out i promise i must be
mistaken what do we call it let me just get
to him no actually don't do that uh hello
mrs graham poor guy steven's here he'd like
to speak with you steven oh i'm almost dead
oh acceptance man poor dude
explains why he's saying such
a horrible person like layla
who abuses him yeah it's just recreating
oh
it's a trip this is a [ __ ] trip oh no
dude oh my god no trip damn no i know i
did it again but i don't know i'm i'm looking
down the street is that even talking to his
just thought he was a call happening
you were just a child wasn't your fault
the gates the gates of osiris come on
dude that's a good [ __ ] show guys
wow transitional shot
it's phenomenal our journey's come to an
end i i cannot stop the inevitable i was
really rooting for you guys but the unbalanced
souls of the duat now must claim yours oh jesus
oh no oh
creepy
oh ouch mark you've got this
that's i've got this too yeah goddamn right
go to bat swing away
oh yeah boom
no
oh no oh you gotta be [ __ ] me now
it's like being frozen over in space
scales are balanced no don't let
stephen go don't keep the chaos
is this house is he picking fruit over there
and the adventures are showing up
just one moon almost almost
done crescent waning crescent
wow we're an episode yeah it's pretty beautiful
that's one process yeah i love that they didn't
shy away from just going full on psychological
inversion you know psychological warfare is
that the first time i've really explored the uh
abusive mom angle it feels like it released in a
way that feels like focal you know yeah well it's
a fascinating way they're handling this because
you know most mediums would do the thing of
there's still three there's still three phases
who's that other sarcophagus yeah most mediums
would do the angle i'll just commit to the whole
thing that it's steven's a made-up personality in
his own mind it's just there's a coping mechanism
the fact that that soul is there in the underworld
the afterlife shows that that soul is
very much real both souls are very much
real both people are very much real and
it's a really fascinating way to do it
oh damn i thought we were yeah i know bastards
face your bachelors you bastards how could you
god yeah let's talk about it all right guys
i really feel like this is gonna be the best
discussion we've ever had thank god coy's not
here to ruin it for everyone christ talking
so fast you can't even hear the points like we
don't need you just shut up oh you're shut up
that you read this isn't the time coin replace
um no i'd like to be totally frank like this
this hits all the cylinders of everything that i
particularly am very much gravitated towards in
any medium no matter what it be comic
book show or whatever i'm this is
if i my passion in life is actually writing and
if you've ever read anything i've ever written
i would this if there was a marvel episode i would
have written it would have been this one except
all the egyptian stuff i wouldn't know what to
do with that but all the other things i'm like
yeah that's like my jam right there that's what
i love and that's the stuff i love and it's cool
watching this and like my thoughts just started
firing because i start seeing all this like
connective tissue of what they're doing with
this character with these traumatic wounds of
of guilt and shame and watching how the recreation
of certain things happens with like with the
psychological recreation meaning you attract you
know um people or events situations that basically
regurgitate those exact feelings and it's like i
was thinking about the situation with layla how
she's not like mark's mom you know that old cliche
of you know you date your parents or something
like that especially if you have unresolved issues
with them you you attract someone who that would
like it's like you would think you'd be in an
abusive relationship or something like that right
and what what i found fascinating was the
last time we saw laila was her blaming him
for the death of her dad and how she then abandons
him or like doesn't abandon him but is rejected
and turned like it's obviously not going to be the
same from here on out and that's a very different
circumstance versus when he his brother died
and his mom blamed him for that and held that
against him so it's a fascinating parallel to end
it on on that exact note despite the fact that the
relationship dynamics are very different
between them so uncovering that package
and when i think what they're doing with
harrow is the the psych ward hero dr hero
the one comic reference i could i could pull
is that at one point mark's dad does take him
to like i believe it a psychiatrist or a doctor
some doctor who specializes in this because he
discovers that he has a split personality
or has d.i.d or something of that effect
and you know they say that this hospital
is in chicago where mark is from and so
i think this is a projection of that doctor that
he was speaking with so this is all like childhood
traumatic wounds and watching how that ripple
effect has carried over into his entire life so
i think it's just really like awesome [ __ ] yeah
it really is and they created such immersion and
such a well-blended psychological mind-bender but
with you know a good amount still of wonder and
you know mcu magic around the periphery and it's
cool because it's an episode that has so much to
do with all the circumstances that have happened
up until this point and some of those people and
yet it it absorbed me to the point where i wasn't
even really thinking about the other episodes
or or you know connecting specific references it
was it was a wonder and a joy and and you know it
even despite it being sort of painful to dive in
so headlong to these characters and to make it so
that i feel like that's just a good dramatic
device is you know in order to figure out
whatever mcguffin or or you know ticking clock
is at hand we need to dive into ourselves and
we need to clear some sort of trauma or confront
something or move some kind of emotional baggage
and they've really made steven and mark and and
everything that that entity is really gripping
and really touching and really poignant and
resonant and like i think in the in the comic
that this draws heavily from you know like steven
is is an imaginary friend at first that becomes
you know the the other personality and here
i thought it was so such a wonderful choice
to make his origin the the kernel of the moment
that he becomes here is portrayed as a direct
kind of response to this this horribly painful
event and i i love that you know i mean they
were talking about the show as being heavy and i
think it's easy to associate that with violence
and even in the ending moments where you see
mark you know sort of you know in that origin
that we'll get to surely in a moment you know
where he's on the steps underneath the conscious
statue like you know there's that blood and
it is you know harsh again it is stark but i
i love that the heaviest stuff is the emotion
of all this and and the exploration and the
and the confrontation of just how harsh of a life
this guy has had and how you could point at any
one of these moments and go that's the origin but
they're all kind of the origin of what is right
now yeah and i think that was really beautifully
handled in an episode that again you have this
you know sort of transition at the end of episode
four and you spend the entire time you know sort
of oscillating within the realms all anchored
by this this um what do they call it you know
they like the construct to organize all that
you know for your mind and making that be this
hospital i thought it was it was like this you
know the promise of marvel on disney plus or
tv or whatever it's like movie caliber television
and i felt like that was absolutely what this was
you know almost 100 well i think what this episode
did is similar to what wanna vision did as well
you know it's interesting when you look at like
the netflix model where was usually like episode
four was when they would decide to do like a whole
origin tale yeah of how they got their powers and
i noticed what they do with their origin tales
here that one division did it i think close
to its final episode if i'm not mistaken and
then this is the penultimate episode as well
is it's not really about an origin tale of
how they got their powers it's more of an
original of why they are the way they are yeah as
people and i think that's a way more fascinating
deconstruction of our of our characters because
you have two characters here you're deconstructing
who are part of the same body part of the same
entity yet the goal for both of them is to each
get to a stage of acceptance you know they all
have they both have a different form of denial
like mark seems to have a logical understanding of
what he's in denial of but it's the feeling that's
the heart that's the things he can't do is like he
knows up here you know like that's like a lot of
the time i'll talk with individuals who have um
i'll talk about if i have patience or something
i follow and talk with my followers about
their psychological problems absolutely
and a lot of times you talk with people and even
for myself uh a lot of times i might logically
know like oh yeah i know why i'm the way i am but
the key to uprooting that is sometimes depending
on like what type of therapeutic process you're
going through is you have to relive those memories
uh not to dwell in it but to accept it and so
you could let it go and that's what they're doing
here but just on a pure visual medium and where
it's very physical of diving directly into it
and it's both of them having to face the reality
like stephen is the opposite he feels he's very
he is vulnerable um but up here is where it's all
blocked whereas with mark his up here okay for the
for our podcast listeners up here meaning the mind
is where he's all blocked whereas with mark uh in
the mind he knows but in the heart he can't feel
he he has to fight against the feelings so i think
that's where the balance i mean it's one way to
interpret it i feel like the balance comes down
to the mind and heart having to coexist as one the
logic and emotion both learning to be in harmony
with one another where stephen represents like a
different emotional side of him and mark is all in
the head about it and so i love that and so that's
where the crack happens on the day of the funeral
just that inability to to rectify the two yeah
it's it's it's powerful it's powerful powerful
stuff and i love how even in the psych ward quote
unquote uh whatever you want to call it is that
there even dealing with dr harrow that's still a
form of them repre like every time they get closer
yeah to uncovering and facing truths they go back
to that room and they go back to the room so they
still need the guide they still need the push uh
they still that's still them both of them fighting
against the truth because even stephen when it
comes time for his big truth the thing he can't
face which is the death of their mom uh he fights
against it and escapes you know so it's it's a
neat correlation as to what's happening to get the
answer to of like this is mom real what's going on
there you know and and it is it's interesting the
choices of the female interest they've had with
the and i don't know how intentional this is
um there is something similar in appearance
and look that they've done with the first person
that's asked out who i still think is jake lockley
uh in the first episode to ask out to
dinner you know get meat get the steak
and layla and the mom they all are kind of similar
in appearance i don't mean that in like a racial
stereotyping way i honestly don't know the
racism of the other two of the act i don't know
the race of the act of actors uh but there is a
likeness that does kind of reflect who his mom is
at the same time so it's it is
it is like very psychologically
poignant and then of course you know all you
get all the cool egyptian stuff yeah two of
going to like i i kept i i did start there's only
one point where i started getting pulled out going
is is doctor strange going to do this because you
see those like zombie characters in there yeah
yeah yeah you're like oh they're gonna look
the same they're gonna have the same design
is this what what this is yeah are we going there
over time is it time for the mcu to break through
and become an alternate personality of this show
well i you know that's what they look like what is
that called the because you know what the duat the
the sea of the the dead souls well you see it's
it's an interesting prospect because if you're
looking at mark specter as as just a pure
individual you know or or like most movies and
shows will take the approach of you are a thing
i have created i have to let you go so i can
be in harmony with myself and be one complete
where i don't feel like the show is going that
path especially because it's penultimate i don't
think the show is going that path i think
that the the bigger realization has to be
presuming because where the wrench gets thrown
in here is like let's presume for a moment that
him being at the field of reeds at the very end
is indeed real you know or is it still part of
his mind uh i'll go off the presumption that it's
real now it's like how does he get out of there
because he has to come back you know there's a
pen ultimate episode he has to come back to earth
you know join forces conscious stop
hero you gotta do all that [ __ ]
i don't i don't feel like the answer though with
the unique approach with this i don't think the
answer is to put steven away you know yeah it
doesn't without without going too much into you
know the spoilery comic book things i i feel like
they're going towards something that will probably
mean yeah that these characters will continue to
coexist in mark's mind and if anything i wonder
if they're going to bring in that theme of leaning
into that chaos in your heart and mind that kind
of comes up in the book because that i could
see as a clear route of you know perpetuating
this character and and making it a thing that can
easily keep on going and two i feel like maybe at
the end then we might get a jake lockley tease and
as much as we've sat here and been like where's
jake uh i've at least as of this episode really
enjoyed the choice or or i feel it rewarding that
they kept it to mark and stephen and had that be
such a lucid interplay and two like i'm excited
to go back through the show and just pick up
all the different like the i have to imagine
there's an expert kind of correlation between all
the different little visual motifs or faces of
people who show up or you know it's like you know
it's like the scales popping up or you've got the
the uh uh steven grant like toys and things like
that that show up and all these different things
um but two just like i loved what ethan hawk was
able to do here too because i enjoy this version
more than i enjoy hair uh arthur harrow to be
honest because arthur herrera becomes a little
one-note comical the further you get from the main
plot the more i'm like i love what ethan holland
he's like he's good on the mortal plane as you
know this this pseudo avatar of amit or whatever
but him as dr uh harrow i think has been terrific
to watch because you know when you're removed
from the circumstances of the plot it also it's
like you have that to inform your perception of
the performance and so it adds to this whole
off-putting uneasy uncomfortable like it the
episode does manage something i think is really
hard which is kind of translating what a sort of
insanity or at least being i have to imagine
at least the way they portray it here you know
this inter-clashing of personalities has to
be sort of jarring for a person and you know
having so many loops where you have to question
your own sanity it's very jarring and i thought
they captured that really well and i loved how
you almost have ethanol at the center of it with
just the most warm and and beautiful presence that
becomes benevolent at times like it almost seems
like he legitimately does get stephen at least to
that point like that whole scene with the phone i
thought was really beautifully handled and when he
finally holds it himself and hears the dial tone
like i thought that was a beautifully supportive
scene between the two of them and yeah like it's
it's he harrow you know for whatever his plan is
on actual earth you know i feel like could be one
of the most memorable mcu villains uh to me anyway
partly because of all this stuff is like man that
is a character whether or not you know like the
main plot stuff is all that satisfying in the next
episode or just amounts to we got to vanquish them
we did it you know well i think with dr harrow it
it's so perfectly suitable to have the
project like marx and steven's own projection
of the doctor i mean i'm under the assumption that
you know mark spector did have a doctor at one
point in his life and that's what we're dealing
with they gave enough clues indicating like where
this hospital is located and a very specific a
very specific name of the hospital like it sounds
like this is an actual part of his past to have
the villain be uh to have the doctor have the face
of the the villain on earth arthur harrow
because that doctor for someone who is in
that much of a denial process considers them
a threat to their well-being because they fear
having to go inside and twist the reality that
they have made up in their own minds like this
is the reality that i'm not talking about like
specifically a person with d.i.d i'm obviously
not that educated on specifically that subject
but on a basic human level um yeah i would i think
that's what they are they're doing with him so i
think ha because i kept wondering why choose ethan
hawk to specifically be him because when you're
in a situation like that you view that person
like the villain especially because i imagine
that mark did not voluntarily go see this doctor
i imagine that he was sort of you know as a young
person was put there or to to you know be studied
or to try to work through this but didn't
emit himself at the age of a consenting adult
yeah absolutely as the sort of last resort we're
just going to put you here and that's probably
going to make the whole thing seem colder and
more adversarial yes and without having like of
parental figures to truly trust i think that that
bleeds over to in the previous episodes like you
see it here with conscious taking advantage of
him manipulating on his weak emotional weaknesses
because it was a cool correlation of how he's
physically he's literally physically dying
but he doesn't prey on that he's preying on the
internal weaknesses of mark spector at that moment
and even with layla in the psych ward she
takes advantage of him as well you know
so it's it's like he yeah i i i wouldn't say like
the mom like takes advantage but in a way she does
because she imposes all blame for what happened
to the dead son the brother on her and it's cool
that what they've done with stephen is he's not
just a coping mechanism he's also a void for he
fills the void for what losing the brother left
behind he found a brother there so i i think what
mark has to get to is a point of realizing like
stephen you're not a separate person you're not
not me yeah i am you as well and and like they
have to and like steven was accepting that on the
boat he was accepting that you see him doing that
like if i i can do so that's why that's where he
gets the badge able to like mess up some of
those um dead lights you know what they are
i thought that was a cool effect just a quick
sidebar like of all the things i've seen in these
shows and movies to create some fun pulpy violence
without it being like gushy i thought the whole
like sand zombies thing was great looked wonderful
yeah it did so yeah i mean i think this is a an
amazing ass episode i really love this one um yeah
quite a lot i thought it was all going to be about
who's the hippo and how are we uncomfortable
who are you just tell us already but i called
the boat you did called the boat called the boat
man you are observant you're a good cinephile
called the boat you did man i didn't think
it'd be on sand but i called the boat okay
the little pirates just sprinkled it i couldn't
help but think a little bit about pirates during
a couple of those exteriors but we also got
the ancestral plane shout out that was cool
yeah that was nice it seems like the mcu has like
some version of uh i don't know some dimensional
underworld like there's pocket world the
pocket dimensions of their under it's not like
you know it's not like traditional christianity
which is earth heaven hell yeah yeah
you know one of the three you like yeah yeah and
it's not just egyptology it seems like the how
they embrace this is there's like pocket dark
dimensions or something else you know afterlife
dimensions it feels like the metaphysics is
informed by whoever's perspective is experiencing
them yeah like the ancestral plane within
black panther uh wherever freaking thanos saw
uh gamora in infinity war after uh being on it's
like a four-minute four beerus and voldemort
yeah after being on vormir and then here it's
like they have and it seems like dr strange will
probably explore more of that too yeah um yeah
this was a phenomenal episode that's phenomenal
and i'll end up with this i have not seen last
time i felt this way was with the netflix shows
um i really hope that when emmy season rolls
around and i don't really give a [ __ ] i
rarely watch a war i only watch the officers this
year because i was in a voting pool and i just
wanted to just hang out with friends drinking
and i was fortunately it was the best option
we got the slap yeah actually it was amazing um
i i really do hope that they consider oscar isaac
because he is incredible in here he's absolutely
incredible it's not easy what he has to do
and kudos to the because i can get distracted from
time to time of you know i rarely become aware
that there that there was a time with any scene
with mark and stephen that oscar isaac had to
do is take his mark and then he had to do a
stephen and then they had to splice it together
i rarely become aware that they had to film it
that way i usually am just so pulled into the
performances and what's going on that i don't
i don't question it i don't think about it
i'm just buying two completely different people
and then when you have scenes like post funeral
when he shifts in and out it's like it's not only
impressive it's like i'm not even i don't know
how to put in a word this is so it's just such
damn good acting and he knows how to embody both
and he can switch in and out of both characters oh
yeah insanely well it's incredibly lucid yeah yeah
for sure and now i just hope that next week they
can really like i hope they stick the [ __ ] plan
i don't really hope they do because it's
funny because like this is an episode where
where it's like you know whatever led before
it and whatever is happening after it i was
like so like this is one of my favorite all-time
just episodes of the mcu thus far and yeah now i'm
just like there seems like there's a lot left
to do though like in one episode i am a little
nervous if they can stick the landing and not
just turn into because it seems like it's set
up to become the problem that some of these
things fall into which is big battle episode
yeah that's what i don't i need to get to
conscious become moonlight i want it to be a
bunch of chaos nowadays and then have like all
plot and and little like you know yeah i want
to carry some of this juiciness into that next
episode and to really feel like you know the the
all the elements because you know you start out
with more of the fun and the mystery and then you
get into the deep psychological and i hope that
the last episode combines both yes you know yes
it's it's neat when you think about
the character of mr knight in the comic
too of like a badass detective in a way yeah you
know whereas like moon knight is pretty accurately
portrayed uh via through mark spector here
uh when you think about mr knight and how
different mr knight is here versus the comic
where he's much more comical but that goes to
accentuate the psychological association of
embodying a personality that is like fantasy
fulfillment because that's what stephen grant is
yeah he's an embodiment of fantasy fulfillment and
and uh you know right down
to the name being pulled from
some movie that apparently young mark spector
was obsessed with no one's last movie though
yeah dr grant and it's funny because
dr grant just would look like layla's
dad in the comic whatever her actual name is
that i'm blanking on right now in the comics
but yeah guys marlene i think yeah i wanna say
whitney but yeah i think you're right whitney
the name bushman bushman not frenchie
in the frenchies on the phone
yeah i think that i think that's all that's going
to be i think decamp will come in later maybe but
but he says bushman is his partner
hmm and called that too and the new
rockstars breakdown we've only really just
brought her up that and like loves buschmann
how do you feel now um probably don't even notice
all right guys thank you so much for being
here keep a lookout for our finale reaction
uh coy you're not missed at all you can rot
in hell yeah i hope you've fallen too much
sucked down into the sun i hope you're i hope
you're doing miserably right now never make
it to the field to read and yeah we'll catch
you guys soon thank you so much for being here
but let's shout out some patrons josiah i am maria
pendley you're the one for me nmb randy you taste
like candy bane jimmy burns was the name of the
guy in the mummy who got his tongue ripped out
in his eyes alan ling you make my heart sing
logan burton unbutton your shirt eric conn's 39
i'm sure your ass is fine ooh
it's cousy cousy quit your fussin
justin smith kill phil eider i'm kidding there's
a bear in the garage nick xylophone juan longoria
i hope i never bore you gail the holy grail
ferguson jaren wanner can get angry like bruce
banner marvel reference stifling already that is
literally what i'm saying stiff cliff rodriguez
chris with the beautiful smell and piss busting
i'd leave her for alex bieber master t with the
beautiful smelling p john the goat seven
don't pee on my face pseudonymous entity
pee-pee ladies and gentlemen i give
you olivia delgade thank you guys so
much to pledging into our patreon your
support means the world i mean it and uh
hopefully we see next month love you
and stay sexy yeah yeah you perverts